انا امنت حياتي اني امشي على رجليه بس مش
اكثر انا قصفت في مدرسه
الفلاح
الزيتون طبعا قصفنا بصواريخ زنانه طبعا
خسرت رجلي الشمال ان بطرت وانا غير هيك
بالنسبه لرجلي اليمين لسه بحطوا سياخ
بلاتين فيها ويعملوا لي تجميل ورقعه فلكن
لسه هذه مش متوفره لس
ف قاعدين بستنى في دورنا زي زي
غيري عدد كبير من الاصابات موجود في داخل
المستشفى منهم اصابات خطيره معظمهم كسور
بالاطراف السفليه والاطراف العلويه وكسر
في العمود الفقري وفي في في الراس الان في
مستشفى شهداء الاقصى يعني فقدنا قطع
البلاتين فق فقدنا اجهزه التثبيت الخارجيه
والداخليه في داخل المستشفى الان هذه
الطفله تنتظر حوالي الى 6ه
ايام اسلي مخت وشي بالوني بستنى اعمل
عمليه
لسلي
الثنتين النتين
اصروا قد نعمل نصل الى 40 الى متوسط 40
حاله
يوميا نستهلك العديد من الادوات الجراحيه
خاصه قسم العظام العديد
من البلاتين اللي مع الاسف انه نفذ عنا
حتى عدنا انه استخدمنا جهاز تثبيت خارجي
اعتقد انه عمره فوق 30 سنه عدنا الى
الاماكن اللي موجوده عننا بدينا نطول
الادوات القديمه اللي كنا مركبينها للمرضى
وفكينا عملناها غسيل وتنظيف وعدنا
استخدامها من جديد وهذا طبعا غير متعارف
في الطب انه نستخدم هذه الطريقه ولكن مع
الاسف اضطررنا الى استخدامها العديد من
الادوات غير
موجوده لا يوجد عننا مسمار نخاعي لا يوجد
عننا مسمار الاستيك نيل لا يوجد عنا
العديد من انواع الشرائح الخاصه
بالكسور يعني اخوي بعد الاصابه يمكن ب 10
12 يوم من قله الامكانيات في
المستشفيات عملوا له عمليه ركبوا له
بلاتين مؤقتا مش مش بلاتين جاهز مؤقتا انه
ما يعاني من الالم اللي هو فيه ركبوا له
بعد فتره كمان ر شابوا بلاتين وركبوا له
بلاتين ثاني منول وجديد وعنده قصر عظم في
رجله قلنا في المستشفى اليوم حركه 58
يوم ضمن العلاج الحالات انه بحتاج الحالات
تحتاج الى وقت طويل الى التثبيت تحتاج
لعده اشهر وبعض الاحيان نلجا انه يعني انه
في حالات انها تتعافى و نضطر انه انه رفع
البلاتين ووضعه
لمرضى اخرين او انه الحالات انها تتوفى
يتوفاه الله فانه تاخذ البلاتين الموجود
عليها وتعقم وترجع تحطه لشخص
ثاني اذا استمر هذا النقص وعدم الدعم
لمستشفيات قطاع غزه سيتم للاسف بتر جميع
الاطراف التي لا يوجد لها اجهزه
تثب
he